to the war in Ukraine now and president
volodo mirzolenski has paid a visit to
front-line troops just days before the
war enters a 10th month zielinski
praised Ukraine's Defenders as
superhuman it's unknown exactly how many
have fallen but U.S and British military
sources estimate casualties on both
sides at around 100
000.
we thank those who are no longer with us
and we will honor the memory of all
fallen heroes with a moment of silence
Russian
ski at the front line in bakmut the
president visited the embattled city to
boost the morale of Ukrainian troops
a very dangerous trip with the Russians
nearby and a now familiar site medals
for soldiers who swear their allegiance
to their Fatherland
[Music]
lies in the Donetsk region which the
Russians annexed earlier this year
since then poutine's Army has repeatedly
tried and failed to take the city his
soldiers have left a trail of
Destruction in their wake
the Russian president was also busy but
nowhere near the front line in Moscow
Vladimir Putin hailed the heads of the
four illegally annexed Ukrainian regions
but he also admitted that things were
not going according to plan
I would particularly like to highlight
the security agencies that have begun to
operate in the new Russian regions it is
difficult for you though the situation
in Donetsk and luhansk in her son and
zapore Asia is extremely challenging
concerns are now mounting that Putin
could have his eyes on expanding the war
Beyond Ukraine to neighboring Moldova
moldova's head of intelligence said
Russia could launch an attack sometime
early in the new year
Russian troops already illegally occupy
parts of Moldova the region known as
transnistria
poutine's War has now lasted 300 days
and another sobering number from the U.N
it says it's recorded more than 700
strikes on Ukraine's Healthcare
facilities since February
let's bring in Catherine Lawler she's a
senior Analyst at The Institute for the
study of War welcome back to the day
that first of all president zielinski's
visit to buckmoo today do we have any
indication of the size of that battle
and why Russian troops are so intent on
taking it
thanks so I think it's it's very
difficult in the open source to judge
the number of forces but what we do know
is that both Russia and Ukraine have
committed a sizable chunk of their
offensive forces to the Bachman area
um Ukraine is obviously defending its
territory but from the Russian
perspective there's a few reasons why
they're so focused on buckmut both are
political I would say the first is that
Russian President Putin is unwilling to
have Russian forces not on the offensive
at least somewhere along the front line
and he's likely ordered his commanders
to capture all of danetsk and luhansk
oblasts so maintaining the offensive in
bakrut is necessary for political and
propaganda purposes from Putin's
perspective the other reason is that
most of the forces around bakmut are
members of the Wagner private military
company and the leader of that company
evgeny pregosian has his own political
aspirations and is using bakmut as an
example of Wagner forces being the most
effective or the only ones actually on
the offensive compared to other Russian
forces let's look at the bigger picture
today is the 300th day since the
invasion where does the war stand
the war is
slowing slightly or you know we're 10
months in and we're in the midst of
brutal winter weather and mud
Rush buses have failed to achieve any of
their territorial objectives they don't
fully control any Ukrainian oblasts that
they didn't already hold before February
24th and things are slowing down because
of the mud and the cold but that
deadlock may not last if we see the
ground freeze solid in the next several
months the head of the Ukrainian Armed
Forces says there's a threat of a
large-scale Russian counter-offensive as
early as January How likely do you think
that is
I mean rational capabilities are so
degraded at this point that even if they
did attempt a another large-scale
offensive it is almost certain to be
unsuccessful but it still does pose a
threat to Ukrainian forces in part
because such an offensive requires
defending against and Ukrainian forces
could find themselves pinned in parts of
the front lines that they don't wish to
be fighting in in order to prevent that
offensive
um so it could limit Ukrainian abilities
to conduct their own counter-offensives
this winter
there is an appearance of stalemate on
the front lines you already talked about
it but that doesn't seem to be stopping
Russia attacking Ukraine with drones and
missiles especially the infrastructure
what is it going to take to end those
attacks
honestly I think it will take Ukraine
taking back the rest of its territory
and Russian leadership seems to be
viewing this war increasingly as a war
of Will and resolve and Ukraine will
continue its resolve to continue the
fight of course but
um I think those attacks are intended to
weaken Ukrainian public support for
continuing the war and that is failing
so they are damaging civilian
infrastructure and harming civilians
across Ukraine but they are not damaging
Ukraine's will to continue the fight
you said that the frozen ground could
lead to some movement again coming into
this conflict do you think we'll see
Ukraine again seizing the initiative and
and surprise maybe analysts like it did
around kharkiv and her son earlier this
year
I hope so I don't think we're going to
see offensives on the same scale as we
did around harkiv or her son this year
but Ukraine has been very clear that it
is dedicated to continuing to recapture
all of its territory and I think what
that's going to look like into the next
year is a series of successive
counter-offensives they may not take as
much territory in one go as they did in
parkive or her son but that doesn't mean
that they won't continue to chip away at
the Russian front lines and to work
their way back to controlling all of
Ukraine's Sovereign territory how
frustrating is all of this for the
Kremlin
I would hope very frustrating
um the Kremlin is I mean intended this
to be a three-day War right they thought
they were going to roll straight into
Kiev and that would be the end of it
that Ukraine would capitulate that the
West wouldn't push back in any way and
obviously all of those assumptions have
been invalidated so now what was
supposed to be a three-day War may end
up being a three-year war or a 10-year
War depending on how Ukraine continues
its fight and depending on Western
military aid to Ukrainian forces
it was supposed to be from the Russian
intentions a three-day War now it is a
300 day war is there any sign that we
won't be you know pretty much where we
are right now
300 days from now on day 600 of the war
if we you know see have to see that day
a lot depends on Western military aid I
think at this point Russia has lost its
offensive military capabilities it's
working to rebuild those and it could
rebuild some offensive capabilities in
the medium term through conscription and
through continued mobilization but
Ukraine has also learned and is building
its own capabilities so I think
currently the trajectory we're on is one
toward Ukrainian Victory but it will
take time and it will take patience and
it will take continued support and I
don't think that I don't think we'll be
in the same place 300 days from now I
think we will see additional Ukrainian
progress it's just a question of how
quickly they can make that progress
Catherine Lawler senior Analyst at The
Institute for the study of War thank you
so much always great talking to you
now away from the finding people in
Ukraine are getting ready to celebrate
their first Christmas since the outbreak
of the war a favorite tradition is Saint
Nicholas Day this year some extra help
was needed and thanks to the national
rail network and the UN Saint Nick
managed to bring some joy to Children
despite the war CW's Emmanuel Shas
reports
[Music]
Saint Nicholas made his way to Kiev
central train station
because no missiles are going to stop
what ukrainians call Magic knight from
happening
must have been obedient even this year
we're not carrying sticks only happiness
and a holiday
since the sky is closed over Ukraine we
travel by train as much as we can
Railway workers have been doing magic of
their own since the beginning of the war
running trains on time delivering goods
and people to safety even Under Fire
as Saint Nicholas said air defense works
well but the sleigh still can't fly so
the railway has become the official
carrier of Saint Nicholas
tens of thousands of children will be
expecting his visit so Saint Nicholas
will travel with some special guests
this year
we are sisters malanka and marichka
hospital
we bring special gifts that children are
waiting for gifts are meaningful they
need them we bring not only gifts but
also magic we give them Joy during these
festive days
UNICEF is providing over 30 000 gift
bags and 100 million dollars in cash
handouts for families in need
the daily strikes are making electric
Cuts water shortages that make children
to suffer so during the holiday period
the Christmas and New Year this is the
time children dream about having a
normalcy having peace and having
something to expect from 2023
[Music]
Saint Nicholas is trained we visit the
regions of harkiv donuts mikolai F and
her son bringing much needed relief and
joy and a bit of a Christmas miracle
foreign
[Music]